you're watching Sky News on the morning
of an attempted military coup against
the government of turkish President
Recep Tayyip Erdogan these pictures are
from earlier in the morning what we
believe to be a government building in
Ankara damaged from an apparent attack
we're hearing reports in the last few
minutes that there are still ongoing
bomb attacks on Turkey's Parliament that
are continuing that's according to a
senior Turkish official that so come to
us from Reuters
obviously the senior Turkish official
has been talking to some sort of outlet
and we don't know what that saying that
bomb attacks on Turkey's Parliament are
continuing right now and he also added
that rebel soldiers have been warned
that they will be shot down if they
attempt to use any more military
aircraft that same official said that
there are more fatalities in Istanbul in
addition to 42 people killed in Ankara